Bachelorette frontrunner Jordan Rogers  still dating I mean everywhere to say  I'm gonna say I'm falling in love with  you and Jordan and Jo Jo Fletcher have a  strong connection on the show but does  he put a ring on her finger in the end  while et has learned Jordan might still  be connecting with other women currently  on the exclusive dating app riah here's  a recent screenshot we obtained looks  like it's Jordans profile his past isn't  squeaky-clean the former pro football  player is rumored to have cheated on an  ex wasn't the best person all the time  not physically cheating but just being  environment enjoying and talking to  girls when I probably shouldn't have  been and interestingly this week we got  a sneak peek at the season finale  Jojo appears to say goodbye to someone  she fell hard for it fell in love with  you when I still love you but what you  did to me it's not  just like a vitamin that I  what do you think does Jojo dump Jordan  let us know on Twitter at UT now